godfrey and jeanette ward have worked
hard all their lives to afford their own
home
now retired their pensions can't stretch
to cover their rising bills or do urgent
repairs like their broken boiler how
much would it be to get a new one that's
it uh i think i said about
2 000 if we paid cash for one which we
can't afford you can't afford it
so no hot water no heating that's
correct
so where do you go you know when you
want a shower or a bath um across the
road
uh she has a shower and a bath
and she's told me i can go up anytime i
want
but you don't like troubling them do
doing really things have become too much
for them to cope with they keep just one
room warm with an electric fan heater
that's expensive to run
jeanette had pneumonia twice over winter
we've had two
bad winters
and luckily we've got through it
but
like jeanette says
i don't think we'll
survive
another winter another winter
money
is the main thing
i don't like asking for things
if i if i can't afford it
you won't get it forget it
so i think it will be
a home
no
paul
for us both no
[Music]
a weekly lunch club run by age uk is at
least a chance to sit in a warm room and
have a hot meal
as prices go up their weekly food shop
is getting smaller
we'll only have one more meal
and lots of tea time
sometimes i go to the chipper
and so sometimes i go to the pie shop
so
and even for a pie now with greenhouse
it's 2.50 or more
we're trying my best to cope
it's not easy
the couple say that without each other
they couldn't bear this
a life after work that's now so full of
worry
so full of fear
catherine of toxie sky news in wigan